[Music]
in scandalous bank news they stole your
[ __ ] and ran yeah pretty much I don't
want to hear that to get the five media
submitted by day and night night
well I'm gonna kid cudi I don't know I'm
not a big he's with Kanye all the time
he's like at every single Kanye concert
that was the single track that calling
you puts out if Kanye was just paying me
to just do the minimum y'all see [ __ ]
Kanye dancing [ __ ] with Cuddy in the
back now that vids crazy dude
you see it looks like [ __ ] Kanye West
is getting his ass beat by some
ancestral spirits
I can't even imitate it it's so wild
dude Wells Fargo says its shareholders
can't sue because they should they
should have known we were lying about
what I've always liked their branding
Wells Fargo I've always liked tario and
wagons and horses you mean a stagecoach
stagecoach a chariot Wells Fargo - yeah
it is so nice you ever go into the bank
and they're just so sweet no I never
been inside the bank
real nice what's going on with Molly
really you haven't heard no scandals cuz
it's been a lot of scandal and I was
like thinking of switching cuz I'm like
well E is like under the radar they
chill but now it's [ __ ] over a lot of
their customers Oh customers I got every
single bank account damn I don't have
that much money my bank is [ __ ] the
[ __ ] know what the [ __ ] batteries
that [ __ ] which one um p qu it's called
my bank quoi
yeah nice of an African Baker thank you
so one of their big scandals here is how
they were creating fake accounts like
user accounts to like juice up the books
to kind of make it seem like they just
had all these customers when they didn't
and they were fined a hundred and eighty
five million dollars for that Oh
and then Wells Fargo said that they
fired 5300 employees for related reasons
to that so that's one scandal so then
this other scandal was where they were
charging auto loan customers for
unnecessary insurance and they actually
knew about this for some time like the
head people of the bank but they didn't
say anything to anyone until there was
like this leak the whole public found
out about this and then they also knew
that it had pushed as many as two
hundred and seventy-five thousand
customers into delinquency and that
resulted in to twenty five thousand in
proper repossession
oh my lord this card's taken away yeah I
don't understand how that happened I
don't really know either I just know the
surface yeah and so because of that it
drove people and because they couldn't
afford yeah they couldn't afford that
monthly payment now but they were told
that they had to pay that yeah I would
be like I'm already paying insurance
fool why do I gotta pay you insurance
that's weird yeah
there are a lot of people who are
financially like just they don't know
anything and they don't take the time to
research so I get it like yeah and then
you think that there's enough checks and
balances with such a big brand or name
that yeah and it's FDIC insured see
you're thinking all these things so you
never think I question if I'm always
fighting with the bank I'm just always
questioning them I'm just like are you
sure I owe you money mr. Collard there's
somebody trying to use your credit card
oh really
let them run it through hey go get me
they also did a lot of improper mortgage
fees and so the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau I pulled my money out
Thank You TIFF and the office of the
controller of the currency find Wells
Fargo $1,000,000,000 for the auto
insurance scandal and those mortgage oh
my god draw before they before we lose
all our mind I got like five hundred
dollars in there scary
so during an investor call in January of
last year the CEO said that the bank
wanted to quote to leave no stone
unturned if we find something that's
important we'll communicate that because
they didn't write that to anyone for
years that they knew
this [ __ ] they didn't say anything so
then that's when the CEO said that but
now the shareholders are suing Wells
Fargo and then Wells Fargo is saying
well you guys can't sue us the
statements that were made by the CEO
it was just puffery which is like you
know they were just exaggerating that
you should have known that this was
obviously not true that we weren't gonna
communicate with you that's not a holdup
it was pretty much puffery usually means
it's like when advertising claims are
vague or transparently untrue like for
example a restaurant claiming that
they're the world's best burger oh like
things like that like that's puffery but
then they're claiming that the CEO
telling the investors that we're gonna
be more transparent with you guys is
puffery damn it's like Donald Trump my
name is pickle what's going on like I
saw like some Trump top right there well
his name is Tim Sloan slime
swamp how the world is it changing what
the [ __ ] is going on with this world
right now
that's wild though people are being held
accountable is what's happening thank
goodness that's why I just hide my money
in my mattress
well you got to move it now do you know
people know where it is why my money
somewhere else
oh you know you could do get a home gym
hide it there no one's ever gonna think
you use it that's joke would it work
like six months ago though now you
actually do go to the gym you just set
out you're [ __ ] sore I do it I go to
a fight you knows your honor I've spread
your money to different accounts put it
all in one and also split it up buy some
gold buy some stocks by some others you
have all my money in one bank account
that's bad it's how much money FDIC
insurance hi-hi worries
what does FDIC instance a hundred
thousand I think is what they -
fifty-fifty
it's either 50-100 Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation do it yeah Federal
Deposit yeah I think I thought it was a
hundred thousand how much do they insure
up til I can't do every dozen oh it's
not what it does it because think about
every single person that they have 250
okay hundred fifty called it I know the
best place to put your money if your
dude buy a flashlight put on the inside
of the flashlight bust a little nuts on
the around it some people want to rob
you they look at that oh we're also
never there's gonna have come covered
cash also you made that catchy covered
cancer must inside of it well you can't
fit a lot of cash in that roll it up
have a couple of my like six flashlights
seems like wow this guy loves
flashlights I went through a fake alien
[ __ ] like oh my god those are girl by a
big-ass [ __ ] dildo but also get a
yeast infection medication put it right
next to it
so when people open your drawer and
they're like what the [ __ ] all your
money I love all your thieves in your
scenario they're like very germophobes
yeah in Bart's world a medication for a
yeast infection is a tub that literally
says yeast infection medication does it
know like yeah that's when you print out
yeast infection medication that's more
that they buy props for movies where
it's just a box that says corn flakes
that store and there's least infection
medication that's like this big I mean
there's literally a cereal called corn
flakes though yeah but there's a [ __ ]
rooster on there you know I went through
a phase the craziest conversations
yourself being all conspiracy bows for a
minute and I was like I can't trust none
of these corporations I'm gonna keep my
money in cash in my room and now I
started thinking about you know how like
in movies the plot usually starts with
you know we heard this $5,000 cash in
this house let's go kill that
[ __ ] I'm not a killer you for
five grand dude somebody will
like $5,000 cash like promised Smurf or
less than that kill somebody for $5,000
I'm not cut out to be a murderer than
yeah well you don't know how poor
murderers are yeah mm-hmm
we've done articles where there's hired
hits that would get jobs for like $1,000
to kill somebody
yeah I was watching this doctor in the
day and like they said that like this
woman paid some guy like $700 to do it
it's like their thought process with
like wow $5,000 I could pay my rent I
could pay for that like that's how some
people will think of it you know they
will they will they will kill you that
murderer probably doesn't get that many
gigs - probably not they're not in high
demand I was thinking the reverse cuz
I'm like oh he's doing it a grand a pop
right what if he's got like ten clients
lined up that one month I'm like he is
breaking in the cash that's what I was
thinking because the murderer of the
assassins that were a suit with the
leather gloves and a briefcase those are
expected probably be like yeah that's
what market prices they're branding is
that pretty good it's like 10 grand you
look like you're about to go through
some [ __ ] look at that be edgy beauty
though no but if you go on like the dark
web like I think the market is like oh
my god yeah of course I wanna I went on
the actual website Silk Road when I was
a kid curious uh it was it was really
scary and I remember when I get like
another browser like a separate browser
I had to download this browser called
tor like onion tor and then I remember
one of my friends was telling me he was
like he said you needed to change
something with your screen resolution
because people can find you just based
off of your screen resolution and I was
like what but you still went on there
well duh because I had to see was now
I'm scared at the time I was like 12 and
I was like what do we do can I google
search dark web and just see images like
someone speak how do you go on I just
want to see an image of it it looks like
90s the internet on the 90s it's just
all unformatted text that's what I heard
yeah it's very like normal stuff that
the
do like trying to buy whatever
Assassin's drugs all kinds of creepy
it looks like a forum what can you what
can you buy on the hard anything dude
drugs killers mmm-hmm my children oh
what the [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] to head of regulated
economy well I don't know any of the
details now because Silk Road was shut
down years ago
oh yeah it was pretty easily accessible
now they're like real hush-hush about
that stuff I'll [ __ ] with that
I ain't explored few years
[Music]